NARRATOR: Located between
the border of Spain
and France is the
Pyrenees mountain range.
The people that occupy
this isolated region
are known as the Basque, and
they have long confounded
anthropologists and historians.
The language spoken
by the enclave
is not related to any other
in that part of the world.
And the population
also has the highest
concentration of Rh negative
blood type in the world.
Up to 35% of Basque people
have Rh negative blood.
And Rh negative blood is one of
the most unusual blood types.
And it's the one
blood type that is
least likely to
mutate or interact
with other blood types.
NARRATOR: Human blood
types are grouped
into four distinct designations
that include O, A, B, and AB.
Additionally, there is another
variance between blood types
known as the Rh
factor, or Rhesus
factor, which is a measure
of Rhesus-based antigens
in the blood.
The name comes from
a monkey from India
and other parts of Asia,
which is the Rhesus macaque.
And this monkey was
used in experiments
looking at blood transfusions.
How blood was received
from recipients varied.
And it was discovered
that the Rhesus factor
could be positive or negative.
Most humans in the world
are Rhesus positive.
NARRATOR: 85% of humans in
the world are Rh positive
and have no issues receiving
blood from positive or negative
donors.
But for the Rh
negative population,
receiving Rh
positive blood may be
fatal, as the body will try to
destroy the foreign antigens.
And for women that
are Rh negative,
mating with an Rh
positive partner
could be detrimental
to the fetus.
If a Rhesus positive and a
Rhesus negative parents were
to have an offspring,
there is a potential danger
to the offspring.
Because these two blood
types can't interbreed,
basically, medical
intervention is needed.
That's why, actually,
in the past,
people had to have a
blood test before they
were allowed to get married.
NICK REDFERN: The very fact
that an Rh negative mother--
her body would actually try
to kill an Rh positive baby--
generates bizarre scenarios.
How on Earth could this happen?
It suggests somewhere
in our lineage
that the Rh negatives
and the Rh positives
are perceived as being
profoundly different.
And also, studies
of Rh negatives
suggest that they have lower
than normal blood pressure,
lower than normal pulse.
In a number of cases, they
have an extra vertebra
in their back.
Rh negative is very rare.
Most of the world didn't
have it until colonization
started in the 15th century.
Rh negative didn't
exist in the Americas.
It didn't exist in
Southern Africa.
It didn't exist in Asia.
It was only in Europe.
So it spread out from there.
Out of Africa,
that theory has it
that all human beings
originated in Africa,
Southern Africa, sub-Sahara.
They're all Rh positive.
They don't have any Rh negative.
Where did Rh
negative evolve then?
GEORGE NOORY: 15% of the
humans have Rh negative blood.
15%.
And scientists have no
idea where it came from.
What they do believe is
that if you have that,
you may have been evolved
from a different kind
of species on this planet.
Now, was that species put here,
genetically altered, or was it
just a natural
formation of the planet
in its evolutionary stage?
Who knows?
But the fact is that
Rh negative people--
and again, there's 15%
of them on this planet--
may have come from
outside sources.
NARRATOR: Could the
Rh negative blood type
offer evidence of a vastly
different pre-human evolution
than what we are led to
believe in our history books?
Might it offer
indisputable proof
of extraterrestrial
intervention in the remote past?
But if so, is the
experimentation
with intelligent hominid over,
or is it still taking place?